here's the mission we got like 15
minutes we have to find someone in
yellow oh thank you all good yeah
appreciate it enjoy your day strike out
the Adventure Continues yellow is not a
common color yellow that gu's in yellow
that is yeah look like it this video is
sponsored by reality scan stick around
to learn more about their free
photogrammetry app and how you can join
us on this photo scanning scavenger hunt
this
week what's up guys we are out here I'm
joined by my very good friends and it is
an overcast day today that means it's
time for photo scanning scavenger hunt
we got a list of 40 to 50 things to scan
we're going to see who can get the best
scans the most points in 3 hours all
right so here are the details we
separated this scavenger hunt into three
tiers first off we got like the Fisher
Price category and these are scans like
fire hydrants or dumpsters those are
worth Five Points the intermediate scans
like cars or trees for example are worth
10 points and 15 points go to Hard Mode
scans like animals or people and for
scanning Pro tips keep an eye out for
the popups on screen real big Pro tip
get ready for losing right like put
yourself in the mental space I have
failed we're going to scan you guys and
you're not even going to know 3-hour
timer begins set 3 2 1
scan
[Music]
my how about you get a a bush Andora a
tree okay perfect so we got a full
graffiti wall and we're going to use a
technique called a stereo pair and
that's two images left and right of each
other and we're going to do a double
stereo pair we're going to do top and
bottom as well so you hit basically like
every angle of this one point in front
of you you're going to take a step and
you're going to just do that down the
entire length of this
wall I say we cut far and then work our
way back back yeah that sounds good to
me I mean we could also scan on the way
going a far of course of course I see a
todoro I'm going to go for it I think we
need it what is a better tradeoff for
someone than a free todoro if we want
someone to scan us genius genius genius
I'm going to grab it I'm going to grab
it okay all
right what's the deal how much is it how
much is it it's
$100 do they have to have a small todoro
oh yeah they have to have a small one
small too dude we're set all right it's
much better than a $100 too which would
have been hilarious I think it's time to
scan this bad boy so now we just got to
finish it out with a higher angle got
you okay let's see if you got it if you
drop
Meo all right steady up yeah ready mhm
okay you going to move left is it good
oh yeah look at this sick hydrant
dumpster o that's a cool dumpster too
yes let's get it ooh woo this is going
to be a spicy spicy one pungent all
right I think we good okayo W that was
incredible work out of the day let's
start moving to our next scan it's a big
rock as a a big rock that's a 10 right
there right there that's a 10 changing
lighting conditions usually screw up
scans I don't think though currently
anyway I don't have any control over the
sun um so you kind of got to go with
[Music]
it I'm so confused we're 3D scanning
objects for a scavenger hunt I think
Justin just landed a the stranger shoe
if you'd be down to let us scan your
shoe hell
yeah awesome thank you Christian thank
you guys pleasure absolutely thank you
thanks
again we got two hours by the way hour
55 oh my gosh what there's so many
peppers what can we scan like 30
dogs excuse me sir I was wondering if
you'd be open to us scanning your dogs
here they're beautiful they'll be moving
around that's okay wait I'm just walking
around here so going have time too okay
thank you so much uhhuh I am getting
this super sweet car but it might be a
bit of a problem because of how
reflective so many of the surfaces are
hard as than it seems cuz the light's
changing so yeah yeah welcome to it hey
I think we're locked we're locked in
here Taki thank you so much yeah this is
very kind of you thank you for letting
us they're so cute just the best that
was uh special that was special tagi was
such a great sport so were the pups you
good Jen yeah good I think they're going
to be I can get it's going to look like
something from the thing I think it's
just going to be some monstrous creation
there is a statue across the street that
we could get oh yeah there was a cool
one is that on the list it is Statue all
right all right all right I'm going to
find something else hey who are these
guys hey hey hey oh my god you bought
you spent money you already lost
man pleasure I'm Jam absolute pleasure
this is a reality scan do like a full
circle then come uh back through do a
full circle low angle do a full circle
high angle yeah that's
good thank you so much bro can I ask one
last favor do you mind if I scan your
[Music]
shoe we're low on time there's a sacred
place up ahead uh 15 points
and
as shoot it's a little too sacred well
oh actually I know a super sacred place
it's back where we started okay so
technically we need a key card to get up
there but if we walk in with purpose yes
I think we can get to the secret garden
on top okay do we is it the very top and
basically
wow crushed it thank you so much yeah
let's try to find that cowboy hat let's
try to find a balloon and a porta potty
those are all Heavy Hitters all right
let's do it
[Music]
found the sacred Place very beautiful
very
sacred as sacred as it gets at a Hilton
Double Tree got it's in the shade evenly
lit I guess yeah this could
work that was
great wonder what Jan's up to this is
probably the most erotic thing I've done
in months yeah all right stay still all
right three
two GG that's all thing we got the belly
[Music]
button got my mini fake a little
Snorlax the lighting is weird it's like
look at this lighting so Jank what's the
plan we probably got time for one more
thing maybe two yeah uh I say we have
todoro here's the mission we have to
find someone in yellow we're going to
give them this todoro if we can scan
them I think that's all the time we have
left for we got like 15 minutes let's
see if we can do this yeah I'm going to
make sure Tod's looking their best
perfect oh there's people in yellow here
we go pardon me hello um so I was
wondering if you guys would be uh open
to us 3D scanning you by chance we're
doing a scavenger hunt and we need
someone wearing yellow one of the other
things we had to scan was a todoro so if
you want this we were like maybe we'll
trade someone a todoro uh you don't have
to do it at all oh thank you yeah all
good yeah appreciate enjoy your day
strike out the Adventure Continues okay
yellow is not a common color I think I
don't think I approached correctly yeah
maybe like hey can I 3D scan you yeah
you came on too strong with a 3D scan
I'm going to do a quick run for just a
police officer all right
okay oh there's a guy in
yellow excuse me sir yeah um uh we're
doing a scavenger hunt a scavenger hunt
when you run around and like and a
person in yellow is one of the things
that we're we're trying to do do 5 or 10
minutes no all right do your
thing strike number number three I guess
should we go up uh yeah let's go up
let's go up let's go yellow that guy's
in yellow that is yeah look like it
let's this is we're running down the
clock with the come on we have to ask
him within the next 15
secondses excuse me sir hi sorry to
bother you we're we're doing a scavenger
hunt oh no we're doing a scavenger hunt
right now no no
oh rejected every time by multiple
people that was hard it's a big ask I
get it yeah I don't even know if I would
say yes on a random day hopefully we got
enough to beat
them I tried all right I have two
versions of this
anyway the scans have been done we got a
toad R along the way we made friends
along the way met a to we did you really
we got we got too reception going on
here saw like 10 dogs and scan them all
at once yeah it was a puppy parade yo so
if you guys want to do this yourself
download reality scan I got a link for
you in the description it's free it's
for IOS and Android so this week for the
weekly challenge I am challenging y'all
to get your own scans do your own
scavenger hunt you got one week to get
as many scans as you can as clean as
possible using reality scan I have a
link in the description down below go
check it out and a link to my Discord as
well where we're holding this week
challenge if you want to get a hold of
these scans that we shot in this video
they are on my patreon as well so you
can grab those too but we got some
points to tally up we got some scans to
look at so let's head back and see how
we
did gentlemen welcome to the scan review
we're going to go through the list of
scans all right all right let's do it he
wow nice very very close to how it
looked like in real life so that's
pretty nice that's nice yeah oh I love
that
[Music]
man
I mean I'm pretty sure people know what
that is though but when they
download whose disgusting belly button
is this it's not
disgusting it's a why is my belly look
so strange zoom in a
little where this yes okay it's like a
I mean Rock if you didn't tell them
context bird would they would say that
even CH we're talking about the clearest
day bird that has no head no wigs that's
still a
[Music]
bird all right let's see here not not
looking good for us no not at all all
right moment of
truth oh exactly dou wow wow it's like
being lapped once on a RAC
trck hey thanks again for hanging out
with me guys I really appreciate it if
you made it this far into the video
please leave me a comment down below
with a suggestion for a massive scale
object you would love for me to photo
scan for a future video but in the
meantime download reality scan hop on my
Discord it's all linked below and join
me on the scavenger hunt for this week
it's running through Friday I promise
you guys it's going to be a ton of fun
you're going to get outside you'll get
some sun you'll learn a ton you'll
probably lose some calories with a run
you could scan a
bun and you could scan a nun